NICK JANKEL: Great to be here.
I'm very privileged to
share some ideas with you.
I'm going to give you the top
slice of about 20 years work
as a committed
philosopher, thinker.
And I spent 16 years
as an entrepreneur.
I started my first company
when I was 24 in London
after reading "The
Cluetrain Manifesto,"
and realizing that all
markets are conversations,
they're not full of consumers.
And that created a whole
wave of innovation for me.
This is part talk,
part experience,
and it's based around the
book I've just published,
which you've got a copy
of, which is great.
And it's about how to have
and sustain breakthroughs
in yourself, your life, but
also in your enterprise.
And hopefully,
inspiring you to look
at how to break through
problems in the world,
really connecting my
change as an individual
with the changes we want to
see out there in the world.
I'll give you bit more about
my life and my background
as we go along.
But as you're
Googlers, super smart,
I'm going to give you a
little question, a challenge.
So put your hand up when you
have solved this anagram.
Come on, Googlers.
OK, we've got one.
A couple more.
Another one.
All right.
Do you want to share it with us?
AUDIENCE: Cubism?
NICK JANKEL: Cubism.
Right.
About 30 people, not
many got it, right?
Actually, you're actually one
of the highest percentages
I've ever seen in a group.
Usually 1%, 2% of the group get,
OK, in a short period of time.
Whose brain, whose mind
was saying, over and over,
"Be music, be music"?
All right, put your hand up.
Let me know.
Right.
That gives you a glimpse
of the challenges
we face as human beings
about how to break through.
Because our mind likes
to hold on to what
we can see now, rather than take
the risk to go and embrace what
might be.
And we'll come back to that
theme as we go throughout.
A little background about me.
Started my career in
medicine, studying medicine,
wanted to be a psychiatrist.
And then flipped into
philosophy of science.
Long story, I won't
give it to you now.
I came out of
philosophy of science
with a good grounding in
social theory, human sciences,
and natural sciences.
And naturally, I go into
advertising, working
for a very large ad agency,
working with PlayStation,
mainly, my first big client,
when they were very young.
And we helped grow them.
As I said, 1999, I read
"The Cluetrain Manifesto."
I saw the digital
wave and was like,
I've got to get up on this wave,
because ad agencies are not
on it at all.
Started up a tech-friendly
startup accelerator
mixed with marketing,
brand consultancy.
We then pivoted when
that industry dried up.
We pivoted in 2001 to
become an innovation agency,
working with many of the largest
companies in the world on very
big projects to develop
7, 10 year products
services, et cetera.
For reasons I will give
you a bit later on,
I then got into
social innovation more
than commercial innovation,
although the two
have become really
nicely connected
at the moment,
which is beautiful,
as more companies realize they
want to solve big problems, not
just small little
widget problems.
And I realized over 15
years of doing this work,
that leadership, empowerment,
individual psychology
and being, is actually the most
important thing in innovation.
So I ended up getting
into leadership work.
I did a lot of leadership
work with large companies.
And then have finally
come into myself
as a wisdom teacher,
which is a very posh term.
I didn't really hear about
it until a few years ago.
I was like, yes, that
sounds like something I
do-- teaching people how
to thrive in the world.
Which as you can see,
kind of came full circle
to my first initial desire to be
psychiatrist when I was 15, 16.
It's been a long
journey, not an easy one.
And I'll share a few
insights from my journey.
So what connects all
my work-- so I work
with very large organizations.
I've worked with Number 10,
I've worked with the European
Commission, and then
working with individuals
on their own life.
What connects them, is my
understanding of breakthrough,
which I have recently coined
the term "Breakthrough
Biodynamics," and hopefully
you understand why,
by the end of this talk,
why it's biodynamics and not
just dynamics.
So that's what holds
it all together.
I run three different
parts of that, if you,
like three strands, three
flavors of ice cream.
The first, as myself
as a teacher, author,
and I did a couple of TV shows
as a present, more in the way.
I run this innovation,
Conscious Innovation
and Leadership Consultancy.
And recently, about a year
ago, set up a new media
company, kind of like the vice
magazine of positive wisdom
content.
That's the kind
of idea behind it.
So big idea.
Biggest idea I've ever had.
So check that out if you're
interested in wisdom, world
change, and well-being content.
And if anyone wants offer
their awesome Google ninjutsu,
I would love to hear.
Because creating a digital
content company in this world
is quite a trip.
So, over to you.
If you could break through
anything today in the next hour
of your lives--
anything at all--
have a think what it would be.
Don't tell anyone.
This is not a sharing session.
Just have a think--
what would it be?
It could be personal,
it could be career,
it could be a work thing, it
could be a business problem
that you're tasked to face.
Another way of asking that
question is, where are you
feeling stuck or
stressed-- something
you can't quite seem to work
out how to get through it?
Or, another way of
asking the same question
is, where can you
see an opportunity,
but you haven't worked out
how to seize the opportunity?
Just have a think of
what that would be.
Go live.
Don't do the dress
rehearsal of life.
Let's take it down right now.
So have that in
your mind as we go
through the rest of
this conversation.
So what is a breakthrough?
It's a big word.
People use the word
"disruptive innovation"
as one way of calling
it a breakthrough.
"Epiphany" would be a
personal version of that.
So just a few examples
to get us in the mood.
So here's a painting, a sort
of Zenith of western realist
painting.
Happens to be about war.
And then this guy
came along and said,
well, what if we did a
painting about war like that?
And what's interesting
to me is, you
could spend your whole life
getting better and better
at painting a
realistic image of war,
and never come up with that.
It's not a better
painting, to most people,
certainly at the time.
But this is one that's
famous, the other one isn't.
This is one that's
worth gazillions,
the other one isn't.
So it's something
to think about.
In its time, as many
breakthrough creators find,
they're not appreciated
as much as they are when
life and the world moves on.
And we'll come on to
why that is in a minute.
Here's another breakthrough.
This is Newton's cradle, basic
understanding of how physics
works, Newtonian mechanics.
Everyone familiar with
Newtonian mechanics, vaguely?
Basically, if you hit one
ball to another, it moves.
And then this came
along-- quantum theory.
Schrodinger's cat, et cetera,
Heisenberg's Uncertainty
Principle, which has now
shifted fundamentally on how
everything in the world works.
I'm sure some of you
in quantum computing,
quantum biology, which is
fascinating stuff going
on there.
This kind of stuff is
happening all over the world.
It was a total breakthrough.
And even now, when
the scientists come up
with new ideas,
a bit of research
came out two years ago,
that out of 24 Nobel Prize
winners for science, all 24
had had their papers rejected
by scientific journals
for the discoveries
that they later went on
to win the Nobel Prize.
That's the highest echelon of
breakthrough-- the resistance
from the existing
world to what you're
trying to bring into, right?
And the resistance
from yourself,
which we'll come on to.
Anyone know what this is?
Anyone know?
AUDIENCE: A video recorder?
NICK JANKEL: The first
ever digital camera.
I know.
A kind of ghetto-blasted
looking camera.
Invented by?
Kodak.
This guy.
This says it already-- "My
prototype was big as a toaster.
The technical people loved it.
But it was film-less
photography.
So management's reaction
was, that's cute.
But don't tell anyone about it."
Why is that?
Why?
AUDIENCE: They sell film.
NICK JANKEL: Right.
This model-- it's film.
What about film?
Who's printed a photo
out in the last year?
Who's printed out more than 100?
Hmm.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK JANKEL: Seeing a
collage, a big collage.
So one person.
You can't run a multinational
Fortune 50 company
based upon one person using
film to any great degree.
Right?
These guys came along, and
many others, and totally
broke through the
industry of imagery.
Because they understood where
value lies in the emerging
future, not the past.
And they weren't
held back by being
in digital-- in
film photography,
in the film business, rather
than the image business.
Instagram is in the
image-sharing business.
Kodak was in the
printing business.
Very different thing.
But what's fascinating to me
is, Kodak had all the MBAs, all
the resources, all the
money, the cash part, access
to the city, access to
Wall Street, consultants,
ad agencies, and these
guys had nothing.
So it's become very clear to
me that power in the present,
does not always
lead to breakthrough
innovation in the future.
And of course, we're standing
in a company that has
massive power in the present.
It is an interesting
conversation to have,
because if I'd done this
talk at Kodak 20 years ago,
people would be,
what do you mean?
We're the market leaders.
We have been for 50 years.
It's fascinating.
Another example of this, Hilton,
the world's largest hotel
group.
Airbnb.
Could have been started
by Hilton, easily.
And look at this, though,
look at the market cap.
This is a few months ago.
It's actually now
even closer to Hilton.
But what really interests me
is this-- 300,000 employees,
versus 600 employees.
And nothing stopped
Hilton creating Airbnb.
Nothing.
There was no one with a
gun to their head saying,
no way can you do
a sharing business.
So why is this happening?
Why are breakthroughs not
coming from companies with all
these smarts and all the money?
And then how does this
play out in the real world
of people and human beings?
Well, you can imagine
going to prison
has been quite a
challenging experience.
This guy, famously,
was there for 27 years
and said this about it.
If I had not been in
prison, I would not
have been able to achieve the
most difficult task in life,
and that is changing yourself.
And he said very
clearly, he would not
have been able to lead
South Africa to peace,
unless he'd been in prison.
He broke through a
problem and turned it
into an opportunity,
a possibility.
Inside him-- not
immediately, but over time.
So the bottom line is,
change is relentless.
We know that.
It's happening all the time.
But you either fit the
world as it changes,
or you no longer fit.
You have a mismatch
between you and the world.
And that's where things fail--
when there's a mismatch.
So by understanding how
breakthroughs occur,
you and me and other
people who understand
that anatomy can turn any
problem into possibility at
will.
And that's what I'm about.
I'm in the business of helping
and empowering and inspiring
guiding people to
be able to take
any problem-- from
their loved one dying,
to an addiction you've
got, to a business
that's failing or starting the
beginning to fade away-- brand,
in a problem, or whatever--
and understanding
what you have to do to
be part of the future,
and not fail because
you're stuck in the past.
That's my business.
So I'm hoping by
the end of today,
you'll have a bit more
insight into that.
So the bottom line
about creativity
is it's not quite
what we think it is.
So there's a myth.
There's a myth that
creativity is linear.
What I mean by linear is,
you start with a solution--
I'm sorry, a problem.
And it's a low, kind
of level of disorder.
There's something a bit wrong.
It's not quite good enough.
You're surviving, it's not
quite where you want to be.
And you walk along
a nice linear line,
making it better,
bit by bit by bit.
And out comes a solution.
What does that remind you of?
A machine.
That's how machines work.
You put your foot on the
gas pedal of the car,
and there is a
linear relationship
between how much you
push, and how fast you go.
But in life, that's
not the case.
You can work really
hard at a problem.
You can go to
therapy for 10 years,
and still not have broken
through the problem,
because breakthrough is
non-linear, because we
are organisms, not algorithms.
We are fundamentally wet,
hot, biological creatures.
And in fact, if you
go into the brain,
something astonishing happens
when people being creative.
So this is actually research
only a couple of years
old, 18 months old.
They put rappers
into fMRI scanners
and asked them to
do different things.
Group A-- read lyrics
you've already created.
Right?
Go through the motions.
Being present, being cool,
delivering, performing.
But you've created the lyrics.
Or free-style.
And the fascinating
thing is, in the brain
of the people,
rappers, free-styling,
the area of the
brain that we think
is where all our
brilliant human reason
comes from, the prefrontal
cortex the thing
that's the biggest in
humans-- this whole bit here
which makes us so clever, right?
The kind of Greek idea of the
reason being this big shining
light of truth becomes
less active when
you are spontaneously creating.
You have less control,
not more control.
Less prefrontal
arousal a defocusing,
not a focusing on the task
at hand, a defocusing away
from the problem.
The hub structures that keep
the brain all nicely regulated,
if you like, start to
disintegrate, which again,
recent research from Imperial,
the same thing happens
when people take psychedelics,
the hub structures start
to disintegrate,
more creativity.
And the brain starts
cycling really
fast between active,
passive, active, passive.
In other words, you are
less smart-- technically,
traditionally,
conventionally, smart--
when you're creating
than when you're not.
It's a big thing to
remember in a world
where we are usually awarded for
being clever in a linear way.
Pushing the sales 3%
more, pushing the brand,
measures, 10% more,
whatever that is.
Right?
So what you realize is
that creativity is not
a straight line, it's
actually a curve.
It's a J-shaped curve.
You start with the
problem, then you go down
and you start having beginnings
of ideas that may or may not
work.
And then eventually, you
get a solution at the top.
And the solution is
usually a lot better
than the problem was.
But you don't get there
until you go down.
So I want to unpack
this for you now,
because this is one of the
most important things I've ever
learned in my life.
Just bear in mind,
I've run probably
150 to 200 world-class
innovation projects designed
brief, specifically to come
up with big new business model
ideas, usually.
And this is always the
process, and there's always
a period here, where the client
says, so what's the solution?
I go, I don't know.
No one knows.
If we knew, it
would be creativity.
We just do the thing
we already knew.
And companies don't like
this, for obvious reasons.
People don't like it, either.
And we'll come on to
more about why that is.
So what happens is,
as the world changes,
we notice a mismatch between
us or enterprise in the world.
So you might have noticed a
mismatch recently in Apple
and the world, OK?
There are things Apple
are doing that are not
matching where the world is.
They spent 20 years being
ahead of where the world is,
and now I sense they're
starting to come behind
where the world is in
various different areas.
I can sense it.
I'm sure many people do.
So when you switch
on, you consciously
decide to go into that
state to spontaneity,
where the brain is less
controlled than it was before,
which increases your creativity.
And that can be done
over a few series
of workshops or meditations or
coaching sessions, whatever.
Then you have your breakthrough.
Then you come up
with lots of ideas,
usually driven by purpose,
which is a big idea
and it's really
important to understand
what your purpose is, what
this organization's purpose is.
Then you start to rewire
yourself over time.
It takes a long
time, it's not easy.
This is just one
part of the thing.
The breakthrough
is the easy bit.
Building it into your business,
building it into your life,
is where things get
really challenging.
And then you get the
results you are looking for.
Has anyone actually
recognized this experience
in a transformation they've ever
had in their life in any area?
That things got
difficult first-- maybe
you had burnout, stress,
worried, you freaked out,
you left your job,
the project collapsed.
And then something came
out and you followed it,
and then you build something
new over long period of time.
And finally you got the win.
And that's what this
win is here, what
I call the thrive differential.
The ability-- the amount
you're willing to go down
to get the up.
I believe that will predict
the quality of your life
in the future.
How much you're willing
to lose control, to let
go, to get that.
Because the other option
is, you notice the mismatch,
you don't do anything about it,
you try and stay in control,
you try to keep your shit
together and stuff down.
I'm not going to change.
I don't care that
my world's moving on
and my relationship
are failing, I'm
just going to hunker down and
hope it all changes around me.
They have to change, not me.
Stuck in a comfort zone.
The world moves on.
You become irrelevant.
The enterprise
becomes irrelevant.
And you enter a
breakdown, ultimately.
Which can look like
something spectacular,
like mine, when I burnt
out and couldn't even
go to work for a year.
Or, it can look like a
slow decay of a business
and gets bought by someone else.
Various ways of doing.
So here's the
individual version,
which is what's in the
book, these 10 steps.
Each chapter in the
book is one step.
And this is my one
example for me.
I had this burnout.
Big problem.
But I went into it.
I was like, why is
this happening to me?
Why I have some kind of
low-level clinical depression
stress, up and down mood
swings, since I was 14, 15?
Went into it.
I realized a couple of
really important things.
I was running a great company.
I had 50 staff.
I was multimillion paper.
I had gold cards of every
description, black cards.
Whatever's going on.
But it was built
around something that
wasn't that wasn't my purpose.
It was built around
my ego and my desire
to be rich and famous.
And it just wasn't
working for me.
But more than that, I realized
I was building a business
around using my talents
and transformation to find
the part of you as consumers
where you are feeling
a little weak, a little
unsure, flick it, and say
if you buy this product we just
invented, you'll be all right.
And it kind of moment
of huge discovery,
I realized that I had to
flip that, and use my skills
and transformation in
creativity and breakthrough
to persuade everyone that
by going inside and dealing
with yourself, you will
realize that you are already
absolutely enough.
And with that abundance
of creativity,
you can go about making
the world a better place.
Because people who are
living in stress and in fear
tend not to be able to go out
and solve their communities'
problems.
The two things are interrelated.
So I realized I had a broken
heart with my own career.
I'd built a company that
was breaking my own heart.
I wanted to be a psychiatrist,
and I'm now doing
marketing and advertising.
I mean, it's like a total flip.
So I unwound the whole thing.
I exited my own
company, which is
kind of crazy-- without
the money, by the way.
Much to the chagrin out of
my accountant and my family.
They thought I was nuts.
Bear in mind, I'd already
left a medical career.
a high-flying medical
career at Cambridge, at UCL.
So there's this Jewish
family, first child
to go into university,
and they're like, oh,
but you left med-- but then you
got this business thing, OK.
Now what are you doing?
You're 30 years old,
and now you don't even
have the business you
just built. Right?
That's the reality of
when you change things.
And then I have
now worked out how
to build two businesses
around my purpose.
But I'm no longer in
the official world's way
of looking at things.
My business is no
longer worth anything
like my first business was.
But I'm thriving, at the
edge of my life in all areas.
And that is priceless.
And here's the version
we use for companies.
Here's a very
clever tool that we
use to break through
corporate problems.
And here's the version
we use in storytelling,
which is another area
where this comes out.
So I have now begun to find
this J-curve everywhere.
And I'm actually developing
another book on this topic,
about this J-curve.
What is it?
Because I've found it
in chemical reactions,
learning curves,
narrative structure.
All Hollywood scripts
follow this J-curve.
Not usually Danish outre movies.
They sort of come down
here, and come round there
and leave you going, I
don't know where I am.
A couple investment.
You invest in a company.
It loses money.
Hopefully it starts to
make money and come out,
but it's a big risk, as we
know from the VC industry.
Scientific revolutions,
if anyone read any Kuhn,
follow the same thing.
Political change,
if you're Egypt,
you're in democracy-- you're
not in democracy with Mubarak.
You want to be a stable
democracy like America,
but it's not going
to be linear, guys.
You're going to have
to disintegrate.
And that's what's
happening here.
But people don't realize that
this can be lead, this change.
But if you assume is
linear, and you're not
ready to help a country
disintegrate elegantly,
without violence and pain
and suffering, you have what
happens in Egypt now,
which is going back
up the left-hand side again.
Because it's like,
we'll if we're here,
we know what that is, and it's
a long road to build this,
and no one's helping us.
Let's just go back there.
Millions of people's lives
are changed because of this.
So, long story short, creativity
is in your DNA right now.
Who thinks of themselves
as a very creative person?
You're in marketing and sales,
so I imagine more than usual.
But still, two or three people
have put their hands up.
Believe me, every gene in your
body is fundamentally creative.
Every bit of research I've
read in the last 10 years
has basically said
we all are wired
for creativity, collaboration,
compassion, curiosity,
and caring.
Monkeys do it, two
year olds do it,
but somehow, something
happens, and we're
less creative and collaborative
than we are when we're kids.
I've got a three
and six year old
and they just want to do
everything together, create
everything, change everything.
So why do so many of
us find it challenging
to break through
our challenges--
whether that's losing
weight, whether that's
stopping drinking
wine during the week,
whether that's leaving a career
and starting your own startup--
why do we find it so
hard to breakthrough?
This is the reason.
We are fundamentally
irrational creature.
We are not Dr. Spocks.
And there's definitely a
mean in the tech industry
that thinks we are,
because algorithms
are fundamentally rational.
But people are not.
All our thoughts and behaviors
a driven by our emotions.
And here's the
rub, they're often
the emotions of a
five-year-old that's
still trying to survive and
protect itself from stuff--
disappointments, frustrations.
Have you ever
reacted to your lover
in a way you know you used
to do when you were a kid?
Anyone's who's married, I
believe you need to realize,
that's what you're doing.
It's because you're
hanging onto emotions
that are no longer
really serving you,
but they're stuck
inside your biology.
They're literally wired
in after 20 or 30 or 40
years of reacting the same way.
And that's what conflict
is-- two people acting
like the emotions of a five- or
seven- or 12- or 15-year-old.
Stephen Pinker, great
thinker-- "Emotions
are mechanism that set
the brain's highest goals.
They probably evolved because
they were hard to fake."
So you can't-- so if you're
like, hungry emotion--
need to eat.
Great.
You can't think through.
You need to think that through.
Eat.
Survive.
Make babies.
Because our emotions drive us
to the three F's-- feed, forage,
and fornicate.
Right?
And then we saw having habits.
Well those berries
killed my uncle.
Don't want to have
those berries.
Brilliant.
I've learn something brilliant.
Wonderful.
But then, presented
with a strawberry,
I may never taste the juiciness
and delight of a strawberry.
And then when we're scared, we
do one of these three things.
We fight, we flight,
or we freeze, when
it's really bad-- play dead.
Hope whatever it is goes away.
Who can recognize
themselves as predominantly,
when they're reactive, when
they're angry a fighter?
Put your hands up.
You get angry.
And who recognizes themselves
as a shutdown, don't talk to me,
I'm out, close the
door, I'm not going
to talk to you for five
days because you upset me?
Call them innies and outies--
fighters and flighters--
and everyone has
one or the other.
But we all have access to
all of these things, all
driven by emotions.
So we are wired
to do both things,
but we're conditioned to
not start creating things.
We would rather be
efficient and predictable
and hope we survive, than
take risk and possibly thrive.
That is the nature of the
conditioned society we live.
And when I mean
conditioned, mean
neuro-conditioning,
repeated ways of behaving.
When at school, you show
someone an amazing creative idea
and they were like, pfft.
And you were like, ah,
don't to try that again.
That hurt.
Right?
And that's the
basic rub of this.
of this works.
This switching on,
which I'm going
to experience in a
minute, is a choice,
to work out how to hack and
master this emotional system--
not just in our biology,
but in our culture,
organizational culture, which
is a kind of manifestation
of our individual emotions,
and our social systems.
That's the basic rub
of all breakthrough
is we have learn how to
hack and master this.
The good news is,
this is actually
from an article quoted
in "Scientific American"
last month.
"People who learn to adjust
and adapt their biology
live longer, are
happier, wealthier,
better at relationships,
more popular and trusted,
and less likely to be
addicted or arrested."
That's what comes from doing
the work of understanding
your biology.
It's an amazing system that
can be selfish and shut down,
or it can be creative
and collaborative.
Your choice.
In every moment, your
choice-- no one else's.
So how do we hack this biology?
Well giving you that
shortened summary diagram
is probably not going to help.
So here's one I
prepared earlier.
I use this with CEOs
and street kids.
Summary of everything
that goes on every moment
of every human being's life.
Hands-- behaviors, habit.
Head-- beliefs, thinking.
Being-- emotions, the heart.
Every moment in your life,
you have a hands, head, heart
experience.
And these max up
in organizations
to processing systems, ideas,
models, plans, and culture,
purpose, brand down here.
Now, most CEOs know that
this is what guides the ship.
Purpose is the top
three focus of CEOs,
according to IBM's world survey.
Big talk.
So, reacting to life.
It's kind of what's going on.
Change triggers fear or,
if someone's in your face,
triggers trauma, sense of lack,
disappointment, frustration.
The stress response
cascades down
with adrenaline and cortisol.
Cortisol kills us, by the
way, if it's too much of it
over time,
inflammation and stuff.
You get tunnel
vision, tunnel memory.
You can only remember
the time where
you made a total fool of
yourself speaking in public.
You can't remember the five
times you had a great response.
And you can't think openly.
Your mind is like this.
Who's been in a
workshop where they've
seen someone go into that
place, and they're in stress,
they're in tunnel
vision, tunnel memory?
There's no point,
there's nothing
you can do right now with them,
until you calm them down out
of stress.
You then react with
predictable habits,
still in the basal ganglia,
ready for being really easy,
efficient way of
dealing with the world.
You can turn off new ideas,
you turn off you people.
You then-- this is the kicker--
you then rationalize it
with amazing justifications
that make you seem right.
And we know there's nothing
that human beings like
more than being right--
usually-- switched off.
And the senior, the
more senior you get,
usually, the more
right you like to be.
Plus, the total doozy is,
your neural plasticity
lessens as you get old.
Who runs all
companies in the main?
Old people.
Not yours so much.
Most of the companies are run by
people over 50 over 60 over 70.
Have got a lot to lose.
The experiences things called
stress-- this is by the way,
we call stress.
And the research is shocking.
Stress is over
50% of millennials
say they've been kept awake
at night in the last month
by stress.
Depression is now the number
one burden on global health.
Number one.
Bigger than obesity
and cancer, according
to World Health Organization.
And suicide kills more
men between 15 and 25
in America than anything else.
More than road
traffic accidents.
Someone said to me recently,
a scientists, stress
is the Black Plague
of the 21st century.
It's killing us all.
It's important stuff.
So let's go live.
I'm going to give
out a little tool.
If you can pass them out,
Micheal, that would be great.
So what we're going to do
is, remember that problem you
wanted to breakthrough?
If you can just put some
at the end of each row,
people can pass it down.
On the left-hand
side of your card,
I want you to write
down how you behave
around this problem--
your hands, how
you think about this
problem, and how
you feel about this problem.
OK?
So just a minute on this.
So on the left-hand
side of your card,
on the side that's got the
mixing desk-- I'm a DJ,
so I like musical metaphors.
Right, on the left-hand side.
Have you got pens?
Here's a few here.
Write down where your
behaviors are-- just
one behavior-- how you
think about the problem,
and how you feel about
the problem-- usually.
Here we go.
You're great.
Here's a whole smorgasbord.
Look at the resources here
we've got in our hands.
OK.
How you feel about the
problem-- irritated,
frustrated, scared, whatever.
No one's going to see this.
This is yours.
OK?
So that hold back.
You're only kidding
yourself of the experience.
How you think about the problem,
and what you dear usually
with this problem.
Pen?
Yeah, use a big one there.
Great.
Try and be as
accurate as you can.
The more awareness you have
over your biological patterns
and habits, the more you
can break through them.
It's very hard to
break through something
you can't see or are not aware
of, slash, probably impossible.
And then at the
bottom of the card,
you'll see a little
box called triggers.
Write down what's the
trigger that triggers you
into this way of being.
Someone not listening to you,
an email coming in at 10:00 at
night pissing you off,
someone saying you've
got to go and do a
talk at a conference
that you don't
really want to go to.
Whatever.
What's the trigger?
What is the trigger?
And there's probably
many, but see
if you can identify one which
gets you into this place.
There's no right or
wrong here, by the way.
It's just what you
notice about yourself.
So keep musing on that.
Try and get one for each
dial, let's call them a dial.
All right.
So here's the choice
you have right now.
Obviously there's
a different way
about being in this
situation, and the choice
you have is to be right,
or to be creative.
But you can't be both.
You can be right, if
that's the right way
to be, given the
situation you're in.
That's the right
business model to have,
that's the right
project to be running.
Or, you can entertain
the thought--
which might scare you-- for
how you have it right now isn't
the most appropriate
way, the most fitted way
to be given the nature
of the world around you.
So that's-- an example would
be, you're in your late 20s,
and you realize you keep having
six month relationships that go
really intense and then
it kind of fizzled out.
Yours could be two years long--
whatever it is for you, right?
And you're like, ah, I kind
of have a pattern here.
And then you have
a choice-- do I
want to keep on
having these, which
seem to be fine in my 20s,
but then you get to your 30s,
and heaven forbid, like
me, in your early 40s,
and you realize that all
your friends are happily
married-- or some
of them, anyway--
and you don't want
dating anymore.
You don't want to be
having those big, intense
relationships.
But you're still
using the patterns
that you have been
using for 15 years.
And then you have a choice.
Do I want to be
right about this,
that all men are
untrustworthy, all will women
are nuts, usually are
the two that come out.
Or do I want to
break through this,
because I actually
want something.
I want to be higher
up that J-curve.
Here's one of the best named
professors in business, Sydney
Finkelstein, who did a
research project that
came out in a book, "Why
Smart Executives Fail."
Remember we talked
about the smart guys
at Kodak, the smart
people at Hilton.
They're not stupid.
Failures are caused by--
he did research with,
I think over 50 companies,
maybe more-- failures
are caused by flawed executive
mindsets that throw off
a company's
perception of reality,
and delusional attitudes that
keep this inaccurate reality
in place.
We can summarize
that by being right.
I did a talk, a
workshop, recently,
with a very large company
in Silicon Valley.
And we went through all the chat
about breakthrough innovation,
it's not going to
be easy, it's not
going to be pretty
a lot of the time.
But we're going to get
out some big stuff.
And the most senior guy who ran
the business unit-- top five
in the company-- came
into the workshop
and was right about everything.
All that.
You could see the lights
on in the senior execs--
it was SVPs I was working with.
The lights on--
here we are, I've
been thinking about
this for five years,
and now getting finally
to transform something.
We had like 15
potentially massive ideas
coming out, very early stage.
The light just went out.
And like, ah, I can't bring
this creativity to this place.
I can't bring my full self,
my full passion to this place.
Heartbreaking for me to see.
So while assumption is
the mother all mistakes,
insight is the mother
of all magnificence.
And as people who work in
marketing, you know that.
Without insight, you haven't got
a product that's going to work
or a campaign that's
going to work.
And often people masquerade
flawed thinking as insight.
But we all have assumptions.
This is my son
cooking in a soup.
We were chopping all the veg.
And I turned around to go to
the fridge to get something,
and I came back and he'd
put all the peelings
of the veg in the soup.
And what do you think I said?
No!
That's not how you make soup.
And being someone who
teaches this stuff,
I was like, hold
on a minute, I'm
doing the "that's not how we do
things around here" sentence.
And lo and behold, that
evening, I found a recipe
for vegetable peel soup.
But think how many
times you shut
yourself down and
other people down,
because you know the right
way to do things around here.
The right way to do a brief,
the right way to do marketing,
the right way to
create an algorithm.
Management's about being right.
Management was born,
mainly in the '30s, '20s,
'30s, professional management.
Alfred Sloan, CEO of GM,
Sloan School of Management,
you may have heard of,
who basically realized
that to create
efficiency, we need
people to do the same
thing, the right thing,
over and over and over again.
I don't want you to be
creative, you workers.
Just stamp the metal in this
way, exactly in this way,
and we'll be efficient.
But we live in an age
of constant change,
when no one has the
right also very long.
No one-- not even Google's
algorithm has the right answer
forever, I predict.
So the question is, can
you break through yourself
at your most successful moments,
like I did with my business,
when I left my own
business at the peak.
We'd just done six
or seven years.
I was just getting people
to call us, rather than us
calling them, which
in a consultant's life
is like the holy grail.
Like, we're in demand.
We don't have to go and
do new business anymore.
How awesome is that?
And I left, because I
knew it wasn't right.
So let's go live again.
And we're going to switch
it on and shift, you
from the left-hand side
to the right-hand side.
And the way to do
this is, is you
know about emotions
driving the whole ship.
We can't start with behaviors,
we have to start with emotions.
You say to yourself
over and over again,
I'm going to not eat
the cookies anymore.
And that night, the ice
scream comes out the freezer.
Or, I'm not going
to drink anymore
and then you're at festival--
oh gone on, then, have a pint.
Familiar feeling, anyone?
You have to get down
to the emotional level.
So we're going to
reconnect the heart,
then you can start with
rewiring the brain,
and then you can get busy in
the world re-mixing the world.
So if you entertain
this notion--
we're getting a little
mindfulness exercise.
Put everything down,
including cards.
You don't need them right now.
You can write down what you
come up with in a minute.
It's kind of visualization,
rather than a pure meditation.
Let's try and get some
ideas out for you.
So assume a position of
some kind of dignity,
whatever that means to you.
No judgment.
And just take a couple of
breaths, just to be here now.
Notice the sounds in the room.
Let them come to you.
Notice any physical
feelings in your body.
And then bring this problem
that you want to break through,
the juicer, it can be a
new one, not even the one
you've been working on.
Like if you broke
through this, your life
would never be the same again.
Bring that problem into
your mind right now.
Just notice what you want
to do with it with hands,
this meaty, juicy problem.
And then what you say about it.
And there's usually, those
sayings, usually come down to,
you're wrong, or
the world's wrong.
I'm wrong, something
about me, or there's
something wrong with the world.
And then, feel the
emotional stuff.
Feel where you're gut's at,
feel where your lungs are at,
feel your heart rate.
Feel whether you want
to breathe big, open,
or kind of short and tense.
So as you have probably
in your biology right now,
conscious and
aware of it, I want
you to imagine all the
human beings right now
in the world who are dealing
with gnarly problems, problems
many of them probably more grave
or challenging than our own.
And think about how many
people coming into the world--
whether they've been abused
or refugees or all the people,
suicidal at some
point, but they've
managed to find a
way to come back
with creativity and
compassion, with leadership.
Imagine how many millions of
people there are, like us.
And imagine how
many millions have
been able to do this since
the beginning of time--
to bring something more
back, to expand their heart,
and to bring more love
and passion and compassion
and caring with their children,
other people's children.
We all have access to that
power, to make a difference.
Just feel them now in
you, and you in them.
And now notice how your heart
feels about your challenge.
And now what you say
about it, and the ideas
that come to mind, why
it might be happening,
what you can do-- any insight
how to breakthrough it.
If I was like this.
If I shifted my thinking
a little bit to here.
If I got into the world
of the other people
who I'm dealing with, maybe
they're thinking this.
And then notice what your hands
want to do with this problem,
this challenge, which is
an added [INAUDIBLE] bonus
to anchor this feeling
somehow into your being.
So a common way is to
hold your fist tight.
Or stand a certain way, sit a
certain way, think of a color
or place.
Just a positive anchor that you
can go back to and bring back
this feeling of openness,
fluidity, flexibility,
collaboration.
When you're ready, just open
your eyes, coming back here now
in this room, in this moment.
Before I move on,
would anyone like
to share how their hands
felt before and after?
It's usually the most clear way.
Anyone?
No need to.
Anyone feel they
were sort of going
to push the problem away and
then realize actually, they
could work with it and more
open, more open-handed.
Any insights come out?
You're going to
Keep it to yourself.
Go on, then.
We're not in America now, Nick.
Americans are like,
I want to share it.
So, what we basically
coming to, and I'm
going to close up in a second
so you can ask some questions.
The dharma, if you
like, the teaching,
the truth of
breakthrough, is you've
got to release the old
before you get the new.
Release the old business model.
Entertain the idea that
your algorithm will not
be there forever.
Or that your project,
or that your way
of being in relationships,
or with your health,
or whatever it is.
You've got to release it
before you can receive it.
There's no room otherwise.
If you go to Ikea and you buy
a whole new kitchen suite,
and you come back to
your flat and there's
the old kitchen there,
what are you going to do?
Like, oh!
Can't get it in.
So you've got to be able
to exist without kitchen
for a couple of days.
It's really inconvenient.
You've got to excavate
the assumptions
that your business
or your project
is holding before
you can innovate.
And the more you're willing
to let go of the assumptions,
the assumption is, everyone
wants to have printed photos.
People value printed photos.
Let go of that to see
what they actually do.
And you've got to break
it down in some way
before you break through.
Because the bottom
line is, everything
will have to go into
break down before you
can have a breakthrough.
The question is whether
that breakdown feels
like a disaster-- burnout,
depression, blah, blah, blah,
or whether you guide it as you
lead yourself to breakthrough.
And it can be
elegant and graceful
and take a day
rather than 10 years.
I know this the hard way.
I spent six years
in psychotherapy,
couldn't break
through my challenges.
And that's why I went
on the 10 year journey.
This book took me 10 years
to write, by the way.
Because I wanted to know that
the science and the wisdom
could integrate and that
I was on the right path.
Most famous and successful
film of all time-- series--
and what's the basic
teaching "Lord of the Rings"?
Is it to go and get a fortune?
What is the whole thing about?
Collaboration to
get rid of the ring.
We don't want the ring--
the ring of power,
the ring of rightness,
the ring of control.
Because the world will only work
when we get rid of the ring.
Because as soon as
you have the power,
you start becoming
a bit like him.
So the bottom line
is, the more you
can anticipate a
mismatch between yourself
and the environment--
feeling stressed,
drinking more than you used to,
relationships are not working,
can't connect with
the kids, whatever--
the more you can notice
that there's a mismatch,
something's not fitting, the
more you could break through.
Consciously look at releasing
your own beliefs and habits
before you break down and
proactively ride this curve.
Because you're all on a curve
in every hour of your life.
Most people just
don't know it yet.
So talk about hacks.
This is about
hacking your biology.
You've got the
capacity to do this.
Every human being has.
There's nothing
you need more than
what you've got inside you.
But I want no shortcuts.
This is not the-- I'm not the
kind of guy who sells you,
come to me and there's a five
minute fix and everything's
going to be brilliant.
The breakthroughs
can happen quickly,
but sustaining the breakthroughs
when everyone around you
is like going, no,
but you love drinking.
Oh, but you're the
person who's the-- you're
the big director of all of us.
Come on.
Let's go out.
Or you come back from a
conference and you're like,
we've got to do a
project in this.
And everyone's like that
is rubbish, ridiculous.
Never going to happen.
That's where the work is.
Because to embody and
embed your breakthroughs
is really the rewiring.
And it could take months,
if not years-- honestly--
to really rewire yourself.
But it can happen in
any area of your life.
So on the back of your
card, there are few things
that I've developed
to make this--
I don't do coaching
anymore one-on-one, or very
rarely and usually only
with social entrepreneurs.
I've spent seven years
developing a DIY coaching kit.
It's peer-to-peer.
It's like the
Airbnb of coaching.
You coach your friend
or a colleague,
10 sessions of coaching,
for like 100th of the price.
21 day video challenge, just
launching that at the moment.
21 of those sort of
little exercises,
visualizations,
seven minutes a day.
And if any of you are interested
in building a new project
or enterprise, we are about to
start a 12 month program using
all those integration
tools I use with companies
to individuals to
develop projects
or careers around their purpose,
and what a purposes is for you.
And of course, I do teamwork,
and organizational stuff,
if anyone's interested in that.
So summary quote, it's
in the start of my book.
A thinker called
Charles Dubois who
wrote, "The important
thing is this,
to be ready in every
moment to sacrifice who we
are for who we could become."
And I will add, no matter
how freaking scary it is.
So that's me.
A little bit of a
sample of my wares.
Please do reach out to me over
the months and years, whatever.
Stay involved.
Michael, do you
want to hand around?
There's a sign up
sheet if you want
to get on my very secure and
confidential privacy blah,
blah, blah, email list.
I think we've time for
a couple of questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we
have time for questions,
if anybody has any.
NICK JANKEL: I like
provocative challenges most.
But if you've got a
question, that's also good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] your
thoughts on picking up habits.
So we've good habit
of daily life.
They give us the basic idea
of [INAUDIBLE] who you are.
And this creativity bit where
you are reassessing everything
[INAUDIBLE] from scratch.
NICK JANKEL: Right.
AUDIENCE: And how that balances
in with your will power.
NICK JANKEL: Right.
AUDIENCE: So if
you have a habit,
you're not using will
power. [INAUDIBLE]
NICK JANKEL: Great question.
So, that's one of the great
challenges of life, right?
Is the J-curve is going
down is only one bit, right?
Then you're going to come up and
build new habits and use habits
well.
If you were thinking
consciously about everything
you did, you'd be exhausted
and you wouldn't be
able to function and you'd die.
And that's why we
are the way we are.
So what I talk about in my
book a lot, and in my work,
in general is creative tension.
And in fact, this is something
I was going to put up.
This is the stoics,
the Greek philosophers,
talked about sage.
That was their highest ideal.
Or the Taoist call it, the
Zhenren, the perfect man.
And what they have
in common is, they
are the people who manage
to integrate these two
different elements.
The-- what you might call
the active, getting-shit-done
person with more
relaxed, mindful,
I reflect and deliberate
and let go person.
And so my work is really
about-- the thing is,
we're usually better
about doing one.
Most people in
this industry world
and whatever getting-shit-done
stuff because that's
what's gets the moola, right?
So I focus move my work
on help building people
to be able to let go
and to be mindful.
Actually, more heartful
more than mindful,
because you've got
into the heart,
otherwise it's just all up here.
So it's about learning how to
be able to go back and forth.
Anyone heard of [INAUDIBLE]?
A great, one of the earliest
Greek philosophers ever.
He always got some fragments.
And one of his
biggest thoughts is,
that people think
these opposites,
but actually, the string pulled
across like a guitar string,
or he calls a lyre, because
that's what they had.
And that's our life, is
this creative tension
between we want to do stuff--
I'm an entrepreneur, right?
I exist, I survive
because I get stuff
done-- more than other people
quicker, hopefully smart,
hopefully better,
but not always.
But my two kids are relying
on me getting stuff done,
not just sitting there
in a monastery going,
om, isn't life beautiful, right?
But at the same time, if
I'm only getting shit done,
I'm not reflecting, I'm
not discerning my purpose,
I'm not noticing where I'm
no longer happy doing things,
or things aren't right for me.
And that's when I start
enter into stress.
I wouldn't know it probably for
six months, a year, two years.
I'll be like, wow, I'm drinking
wine every night again.
Hmm.
Something's probably
there, right?
So that's the work, right?
The work of this work is
being able to be able to go,
you know what?
This is now a
creative brainstorm,
breakthrough workshop.
Permission for two days
to think any thought.
No thought is right,
no thought is wrong.
We're going to get through
all our assumptions
and actually get to the very
basic bottom of this industry.
But in this workshop, it's
a get stuff done workshop.
Now you can still
question and hold up
some thoughts and
whatever about it,
but we're not really
here to question anymore.
We'll come back to that again.
And be able to do
that in yourself
in moments-- in and out,
in and out, in and out--
is where the great is--
Eudaimonia, thriving.
Being able to flip between
active and passive.
Habits, building the
habits, and then being
spontaneous able to
go, you know what,
let's not go on this
holiday today, let's
go camping instead.
And your kids are like, yeah!
Because you felt it.
Has anyone seen
the film, "Selma"?
"Selma," about
Martin Luther King?
So the whole thing was
about the confrontation
between the Southern police and
whatever, and then the people
who were the civil
rights movement.
It's where the whole
thing changed in America.
And so Martin Luther King has
been walking on this bridge.
They'd been shot at and
beaten up and whatever.
And he puts a call out to
other people around the country
to come.
So they all come to Selma.
A few weeks after this,
Lyndon Baines, LBJ,
created the Civil Rights Act.
So this is the turning point.
And they're all about to
go confront the police.
And instead, he pulls
them all them all down,
taps into his
intuition and goes, no.
And asks everyone to go.
And the next scene
in the film is a guy
going, but everyone parade.
He goes, he tapped
into his intuition.
He let go of the
plan in order to do
was he realized was
right in that moment.
And the higher up you
get in an organization,
the more you have
to trust that thing.
Because there's no public
data for the future.
And I call it intuition,
but you know, people call it
different things.
One more question?
I'll be here for half an
hour, if anyone wants to.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we're
going to go for lunch.
If anyone wants to come for
lunch, let's leave at 1:30.
So, thank you very much, Nick.
NICK JANKEL: Thank
you very much.